We Begin this hour with a new look at a
key moment in the Civil Rights Movement
many Americans know the story of Emma
too the 14 year old black boy who was
brutally murdered in Mississippi in
1955. he was visiting from Chicago and
accused of whistling at a white woman
two white men were acquitted of the
crime of an all-white jury of course
they later admitted to the killing a new
film till it focuses on one of the most
important but often overlooked people in
the story and it's mother Mammy the
movie follows her efforts to draw
attention to what happened to her son
who she called Bo it also features her
work as a civil rights activist after
his death take a look
it's not a bad thing for him to know
where he comes from Chicago is all he
needs to know
I want him seeing himself the way those
people are seeing down there
those people like me
even you left Mississippi mama
Bo is growing up
you're gonna have to let him go
all right I know that face that is the
face of Mama mind your business and go
home where's my pocketbook right here
we're joined by producer Whoopi Goldberg
who plays Mamie's mother that's in its
grandmother in the film's co-writer and
director chinoychuko how you doing good
morning good morning thank you for
joining us now we'll be we hear that you
have worked to get this film on the big
screen for more than 20 years well
that's actually the the originator of uh
trying to get it up his name is Keith uh
Beauchamp okay and he is the reason that
we know as much as we know because he
spent much time with Mamie and also he
created the documentary that got the
case reopened so this has been he's been
on this to get this done he wanted to
get it done before Mrs uh till passed
but we weren't able to get that done but
I'm on it 11 years trying to get it done
we said the introduction that many
Americans know know the story of Emmett
Till but the reality is many Americans
do not right how do you hope that this
movie changes their understanding of the
case
I think most of us don't know about
Mamie till Mobley and who she was and
how she was a catalyst for the modern
American Civil Rights Movement without
me tell Mobley the world wouldn't know
who Emmett Till was and so she's the
heartbeat of the story and so watching
this film there's so much to learn about
her and all and all the people who are
part of the story like Dr trm Howard and
Merle Evers Medgar Evers yeah Mound
Bayou etc etc you know what you guys did
so beautifully is you humanized Emmett
we saw him as a young teenage boy it
opens with him and his mom singing in
the car it shows that he liked to play
it shows that he was a playful really
great kid and I think that that's so
important to see the humanity of both of
these characters that said it was so
difficult chinoya to watch so difficult
and so painful and I've heard people say
I I don't think I can watch it why do
you think it's important that people
look at this movie well first it's it's
important for people to know that this
movie was is made with care you know and
care for the story care for audiences
you know that there's an intention
behind not showing the physical violence
on screen
um and we never actually saw the
violence never actually saw the violence
and even when we do see Emmett's body
it's the camera it does not objectify
him it's not their voyeuristic lens but
it's to capture the love and connection
between Mimi and her child and so this
and I will also say you know even though
there are moments of sadness and and
deep pain there's also Joy yes and
Community that's what was so beautiful
about it because we got to see the real
she was his only child number one I
didn't know that we got to see the deep
love and Whoopi you pay the grandmother
clearly your acting chops are very much
well alive alive and In Living Color but
you play such a crucial role because Mom
didn't want him to go Mamie didn't want
him to go and his grandmother said oh
let the boy go it'll be a good
experience and I don't think she ever
got over oh but you know what this movie
is this is you know how
you learn through film you learn about
what happened in the world you know and
for us you know
it's not that you you don't want to see
it you do want to see it I think you
need to see it you have to see it but
what you have to remember is that unless
you come and take part in this you can't
fix it because this is the this is
exactly what
racism at its absolute worst to systemic
racism looks like it allows people to
kill your children it allows you to be
dehumanized as a person I mean the
reason we're talking about the fact that
you know Emmett's been humanized is
because people don't think of him they
think of him as a as a picture in
America that's it but this a horrible
grotesque figure yes but when you when
you realize this was a little kid yes
Somebody's Baby Somebody's Baby you know
which she said repeatedly yeah you're
showing you're you're shot your shot
choices I thought were Exquisite we see
Mimi's eyes close up when we first see
the body after we know what's happened
you deliberately don't I wonder was it
deliberate because we didn't see it and
I sat there bracing myself for thinking
I don't want to see it it was just
Daniel's face who's brilliant by the way
yeah but then later in the funeral home
you did show it what was your thinking
on that was that a deliberate Choice it
was a deliberate choice you know I I
wanted this film to stay within Mamie's
emotional point of view and so and her
emotional experience of seeing her son's
body so that's why when touching her
son's body touching her son's body
connecting with her son's body and so
that is what the scene was about and so
I wanted the camera to capture that yeah
you know you talked about not being in
the right mental space or
hoping that you could be in the right
mental space after being involved in
this project
what kind what type of energy are you
left with yeah these projects change you
right I mean working this closely on a
story like this it's got to alter you
yes I mean I
I did not know much about this story
that I thought I knew a lot about you
know Tony's point is right you know so
many people think they know this yeah
you have no idea and you just learning
more about who made me what like she
already was a Shiro but then just really
understanding her story it's it's yeah
it's transformative and also I didn't
know about Dr trm Howard yeah you know
before before going on this journey I
mean and I think he's an unsung hero you
know who's on who was brilliant is
Danielle tell us about actress Danielle
she should go get her awesome dress
ready this is for sure this woman
who plays her performance yes is
transformative you've never seen
anything like that for me it is just
watching her
was
Heaven you know how did you know that
she know he was the right director for
this project because she said the stuff
that Barbara broccoli and Fred Zolo and
Barbara James yes yes she's one of our
other executive executive producers and
we looked long and hard we've been
looking for a long time for somebody and
chinoya came in and said exactly the
stuff we had been talking about because
we felt that if we were to
show stuff that people already believe
they see when they see it it's it's not
it doesn't convey what we need and it
needed to come from
uh from Mamie and so the second thing
she said well it needs to be told from
the mother's point of view we're like
and I don't really want to show the
volume I was like so you're going to do
it you remember how fast we sat you're
in right because I was like like that
right because really this is this is a
way to learn the way you know we've
learned from other horrific things in
history and Frank that's how we learned
about the Holocaust was through Earth
through this kid yes we want people to
learn what systemic racism what the what
the outcome of system through the lens
of a woman who lost the most precious
thing that she has through a woman who
brought as much dignity to an
undignified unspeakable tragedy unspeak
unspeakable I still think about her
decision to allow us to see it where she
said I want them to see how powerful
that was yes
to my child and she was right yes
because people wouldn't have believed it
exactly you know just like they don't
believe it now when you say this is what
happened people say oh yeah okay and the
men the men eventually uh were found
guilty and they were they admitted that
they were acquitted and then later in an
interview yeah we did it yeah and
they're paid four thousand dollars so
egregious yeah all the way around yeah
thank you so much we appreciate your
presence in this film till we'll be in
theaters everywhere tomorrow
make sure you check it out it's a must